oh
hello all right
sorry i'm running a little late uh folks
are gonna have to let me know if you can
hear me
all right still fiddling with this new
setup
and trying not to knock stuff over
all right i might even get this
something vaguely resembling
standardized one of these days
we shall see
uh
diluting my diet coke with water that
should offset
the caffeine it depends on what the
water is i suppose
spicy water
ah thanks for letting everyone know i
was running a little late carolyn sorry
about that
um i wish i could say i had a good
reason
i really don't i was just scrambling at
the last minute
uh i'd like to assure you that i'm not
blinking
good to know ben don't blink
whatever you do
so here's the uh something that i've
i've realized
slapping this thing on for the first
time in a while um
i i really need to get a binder at this
point
because um we'll see if uh hold on
just ah there it is
that that just goes right there
um granted part of the problem is that
this is a
shirt with snaps instead of buttons um
because it's
actually uh a shirt that i use for
burlesque so i need to be able to snap
it open
uh on fairly quick notice but it's still
a problem because even if it was buttons
they would be
strained so it's the price of boobs
could really use some emotional support
right now i haven't been in a good place
financially for the past three weeks
because i've been stuck in quarantine
without pay oh my gosh
connor i i really hope
that things get better for you soon
i i wish that i could offer more than
just
words um but that's what i've got and
i hope that you see the better side of
what's going on and i hope you do soon
i really do cheers
i would like to apologize again for
doctor in distress you should
ben you absolutely should
but at least you only have dimensions in
time to get through now yeah see you say
that except i have canine and company on
the docket
cause somebody actually commissioned me
to do that one
oh boy
i celebrated my 30th birthday on
saturday happy birthday rebecca
uh with two close friends indian take
out ooh beauty and the beast on disney
plus
the uh the real version i'm hoping
the original uh i got criminal minds
complete box set from my parents ooh
i never got into that show i kind of had
grown out of
procedurals by the time that one started
to become big i'm realizing how many
wolves we have in the chat we have
rebecca we have ms wicked wolf it's um
it's quite the uh quite the pack we've
got going
nicole cassell is remaking the wizard of
oz what are your thoughts
i don't know who nicole cassell is
so without knowing who that person is
or what studio is backing it or
whether it is attempting to remake the
uh musical or whether it is
um trying to
re-adapt the original work from scratch
my opinion is going to change based off
a lot of information that i don't
currently have
i hope you get i hope you get better
from your hard times in life also
screw you ben yeah willow i seem to
recall you being a pusher for that
too if my memory serves
with all the wolves maybe next time
dressed like red riding hood
i have the wrong color hood i do have a
hood uh but it's green
what's your favorite outfit for outfit
for the doctor we're off to a good start
mine is the fourth um that's
honestly really hard to say
uh because
i think so much of it is driven by their
personalities and most of them have
an outfit really befitting their
personalities like purely aesthetic
i'll tell you for cosplay i really do
like 13s
um aesthetically i kind of like series
10
capaldi the sort of he's got the fancy
coat but then just
you know these raggedy hoodies and like
i love the contrast of that
i am absolutely um
not going to be able to keep up with the
chat i'm going to warn you right now
folks it is zooming by me
uh so 10th doctor outfit for burlesque
don't blink i haven't used this
um full thing for burlesque
before but this shirt specifically um
was i had it done up with snaps uh liz
actually
did that for me because i can't hand sew
um new miking camera sort of the mic is
actually what i've been using
for the videos for a while um the webcam
is new and because i'm using that i'm
able to now actually stream through my
computer again so i can use my good mic
um but anyway the the shirt was done for
snaps
because it was going to be part of a
brad number from rocky horror picture
show
which was the which was the theme for
the show that was supposed to happen
in march of last year which was the
first one that
didn't happen because it was cancelled
because
because the world so um
this this shirt though it's ready has
not seen action yet
nice mike did you hear the mandalorian
star pedro pascal
introduced uh to the world his
transistor
uh luxon wax poetic about her i had not
heard
that one's news to me greetings from
spain i'll watch it delayed with
automatic subtitles to understand it my
english is terrible
um your english cannot possibly be worse
than my spanish
so
take that for what you will what were
you planning for twitch
um my
my interest in twitch um at least for
right now
because until i get a um
[Music]
until i get a whole new computer and a
decent rig
i have no business even trying to run
modern or more recent games much less
try and stream them
so i i would my interest initially was
more
at the notion of playing some older
games
that i haven't played in a while um
like i was thinking of getting my hands
on
uh maybe the the remake of full throttle
or
booting up uh the original diablo which
actually i'm gonna have to do anyways
because
um at some point hopefully this year
god that's how far out i'm trying to
plan at this point i
want i want to do um kind of a video
essay thing of my own
sort of journey through the diablo
franchise
um because like i read that's that's
about the only
pc specific franchise that i really
stuck with for a while
and i um
i would uh i would like to do that and i
i would have to capture footage for that
anyways
so if i need to do that i might as well
stream while i'm doing it
um so many things have gone by while
i've taken my
long ass time answering that question i
watched your from dustil dawn review
earlier today gotta say you're funny
when you're drunk
good to know um i'm la
i'm loud when i'm drunk is what i am
i am loud and flirty that that is my
drunk
uh to be more precise i'm back at work
but my finances are not in good standing
at all i really really really hope i can
bring myself back
to financial stability okay that's
all right that's slightly better conor
than uh than the impression i got on
your
on your first message
what i can tell you having been in and
actually am currently
still if we're being completely honest
in a bit of a tight financial space
like just cut things to the bone
anything that can wait like
payment financially anything that can
wait
let it wait anything that can be cut
cut it it's going to suck and you may
have to do that for longer than you want
but hopefully it will help you
get your feet under you again and i
don't i i honestly actually don't like
giving that advice
because it's effectively a variant of
the old um well we're gonna have to
tighten the belt which is something that
people of means always say to people
who are living paycheck to paycheck and
it really actually
pisses me off but
realistically sometimes that's all you
can do
so i i still wish you absolutely the
best of luck
thoughts on diablo 4 then diablo 4
as far as i'm concerned doesn't exist
i know diablo immortal is supposedly a
thing it's going to be mobile don't care
my intention is only to talk about the
first three games because
those are the ones i sunk a lot of time
into the second one especially holy crap
did i spend a lot of time on that game
uh i tend to be more sociable when i'm
drunk
um i was debating whether or not i am
i don't know because
i usually will only drink to the point
of actually getting drunk
if i'm already in a sociable mood
it's not something i usually do alone
unless i've been paid to do it
so um that
uh i don't know what comes first chicken
or the egg on that
did you review the entire watchmen
sequel or are there episodes left
i have seen all of them i have shot on
my reviews i have not put
up the review of the finale yet that
will go up later this week
but i did finish it and it was
excellent you say that like it's a bad
thing
which thing was like a bad thing i'm
assuming you mean not my
being loud and flirty
it is what it is uh
i get what you mean i i've
been really taking tight measures to
make sure i don't end up
with backdraft fees yeah i mean that's
the kind of stuff you have to do
when i um
when i lost my job in july
i sat down and wrote out my expenses and
i didn't even write out you know stuff
that i
knew i had tended to spend money on
but like if it was optional i didn't
even write it down i wrote down
like roughly what i spend per month on
bills
that i need to pay my electricity
my heat my water my internet
and then um figuring out what i
need to be able to do my work
which did which i lumped together the
streaming services that
i have and i had to figure out taxes and
all that and
just write down the bare minimum what
if i cut everything to the bone how much
do i need to be making and
it's tight i'm still living tight i'm
probably gonna be
continuing to live tight for a while i
i wish i could say that as
soon as the pandemic measures are lifted
i'll start you know going to conventions
and
things like that but i can't promise
that because i can't promise i'll be
able to afford it
and it's a frustrating thing because
like that sort of thing i can actually
write off it's
it's effectively a um
a business expense for me at this point
but even if you can write something off
later
on your taxes you still have to be able
to pay for it initially
which that's that's sort of where i'm at
diablo 2 and 3 are among the best games
ever in my view i it took a little time
for me to come around on to three
i'll be completely on and that is one of
the things that i i hope to talk about
um when i eventually get there
thanks for keeping on top of things
caroline i really appreciate that
uh did you hear that stacey
oc cofour uh
story editor and writer for watchman is
writing the mcu blade
i did not know that ooh
that's exciting just popping in to say
hi
been binging buffy an angel with a
friend these past few weeks oh well
that sounds like fun is it something
your friend has seen before or is it new
to them because that's always extra fun
uh do you uh do you have one of those
doctor who mugs
where you put hot liquid in it the
tartar tardis travels from earth to
space
i want to yes um and the fact that the
tardis is already gone
um indicates that this has kind of gone
cold and i'm
drinking it anyway
because i'm not picky and i
actually might even be a lush but there
you go
nicole cassell is the director for
watchmen and newline cinema is in charge
of the remake okay
but i'll come back to my bigger my big
question on that which is
is it an actual remake
of the film the wizard of oz or is it a
new adaptation
of the original novel because those are
two very different things
given that it's new line i'm going to
assume it's the latter
in which case i will shrug until i see a
trailer
you realize people may ask you to do
drunk reviews for
with nail and i are leaving las vegas
now i am aware that i have opened the
door potentially to all kinds
of drunk review requests but even in a
drunken state i knew enough to say
in that review i do not promise that i
will do this on request again
so if uh if somebody wants to
um commission a review
and request it be drunk you can request
that i can't promise i'll do that latter
part
just because you know it's only so many
hangovers a girl can take
goodness
what is that in there
i don't know what that was uh
more like a retelling of the books okay
like and that's fine
i don't think i it's actually kind of
funny that there hasn't been
a major studio crack at
re-adapting the original wizard of oz
really since um
that the musical version the judy
garland
version came out um
it it's very
straight like uh i know initially there
there
was actually rights issues but then
later once once
it went public domain people still
wouldn't touch it because that original
film was so dang iconic
instead they tried adapting later books
like with return to oz or they did
weird reimaginings or parodies but like
no one's tried to adapt
the original work straight and given how
different the film version is it's worth
doing
excuse me what's with the 4-3 aspect
ratio um
it has to do with the webcam and i have
not sorted out
why uh i can't get it
in a wider view than that yet i'm trying
to figure that out
um or at least i i have been when i
noticed it realized oh right i should
figure that out and then i don't think
of it again
until i turn on the webcam again and
then i notice so
it's one of those things that i probably
won't actually start to
look into trying to figure out how to
fix for a while
because you got a nice a nice space
background
so pardon me folks i actually need
to touch up nails so you have to watch
me do that too
i remember drunken humans reaction that
was fun
i considered um doing drunk reactions
part of the problem there
um is that reaction videos are
frankly a real big pain in the butt
to edit for me
um partly because you know i
you know with the trailer reactions on
the break room it's one thing i'm you
know it's a short video they're easy to
edit
and i usually don't get i those videos
usually get copyright claimed
um which isn't like a dmca takedown and
they don't
restrict the video or anything but i
don't i don't make money off those
so i wouldn't be able um
to have like the smaller version of the
thing i'm watching
so that you could see it and know what
i'm seeing so you'd have to like cue the
thing up yourself
plus with my good camera it's a weird
thing and i don't know why this is the
case but it won't
continuously record past 24 minutes
after that i have to restart it again
which if i'm drinking i'll probably
forget to do and then i won't end up
with everything
what's your favorite doctor who cosplay
that i own
uh that's um that's 13's
outfit i'm quite fond of
i am missing all kinds of questions
uh with ocean's 11 turning 20 this year
oh my god
i need a drink now
dear god 20 really
hey there channel pup yes it's 4 3. um
i enjoy ocean's 11 i always have i've
i've always thought of it as the
cinematic equivalent of a jam session
it's just a bunch of professionals who
were really good at their craft
getting together and just just riffing
off each other just
vibing just yeah let's just
let's just have fun together and maybe
people want to see the result
that's that's what i feel like the first
oceans movie is
uh ocean's 12 was oh god i never got
around to 13. i did actually enjoy
oceans eight people seem to like to crap
on that one i actually quite enjoyed it
uh i mean 11's still better but you know
any plans for valentine's day uh no
cause i'll have my kid
besides which liz and i you know we went
back and forth do we you know do we want
to do something a little bit later do we
want that but it's like what the hell
are we going to do
restaurants are closed or they're only
doing takeout
and so like getting take out and staying
in we do that
anyway um it's not a holiday
either of us are huge on so like i
i've gotten her some some little things
um
she's gotten uh me some things i
she's mentioned but like actually doing
something i don't i don't think that's
um that's in the cards this year
drunk review of dimensions in time has
to be a thing
pay me
you know what maybe what i need to do
is flip what i said on its head where if
people want to
um commission a drunk
review uh i can't guarantee i do it
maybe i need to flip that around
where i don't think i'm gonna review
anything drunk
unless somebody pays me to do it part of
me was
tempted to do my
eventual review of
the justice league snyder cut drunk
except that like i feel like i
should give the thing its best
possible shot to be good um
i think that's only fair at this point
i still don't think i'm going to like it
it's still probably going to be bad
but i i figured the the least i can do
is try and give it a fair shake
favorite matt favorite master theme i
actually can't even remember missy's
theme
off the top my head
um
you can only choose one beetlejuice or
the nightmare before christmas oh
beetlejuice you're very into the
pick one questions ms wicked wolf
i'm annoyed at disney today oh did
did i me did i miss something carolyn
what did disney do now
excuse me
uh is the first ninth doctor adventures
box set
ravagers a big finish set you'll buy
without hesitation
funds provided or will you wait for
reviews like i don't
read reviews of big finish i get what i
want to get
um so like i'll get it
i probably won't be able to afford it
um right when it comes out big finish is
not cheap they're good they're great
they're really good at what they do but
that's that stuff is
pricey people it really is
pirates they've decided to shut down
blue sky and kill the nemona
adapt no
oh
okay so
[Music]
i won't lie i was
nervous already about
the idea of pneumona
being adapted by blue sky because the
only film that blue sky ever made that
was any good
was the peanuts movie or like was better
than just mediocre
was the peanuts movie and that one was
probably only good because the
shoals um family
had a very strong hand in making sure
they didn't screw it up
so i did not have a lot of faith in blue
sky
to do pneumona justice
that having been said
if disney was gonna kill it i would
hope that they would retain the rights
to that film
and shift it to their stand to another
animation department somewhere cause
ah they are really letting money slip
through their hands if they just
let the rights to the film right cinema
lapse and fall to somebody else
and they're usually good about that i
say good they're
you know they're a corporation like any
other but they're usually
smart about not letting something fall
out of their
grip in terms of uh ip
management huh
i'm also into getting you to sing uh
i mean the thing about me singing is
still the issue of if i sing more than a
little bit
i risk getting the um
the archive of the stream copyright
claimed which kills the
um the chat playback
for reasons i've never really been able
to fully understand
because uh youtube is
kind of broken in a lot of ways and
they have very little incentive to jump
on
fixing a lot of it because the system as
it exists
is beneficial to them
and they don't really care
what is beneficial to create like at
this
at this point i have pretty thoroughly
lost faith in the youtube algorithm
um just looking at my own
recommendations feed
about 60 of it is stuff i've already
seen
so the fact that they are trying to get
me to re-watch stuff that i've already
seen before
it doesn't give me a lot of hope that
they're promoting my stuff in front of
people
who aren't familiar with it apparently
the wizard of oz
remake will be a mix of both the
original movie and the book
okay so that would have to be in
partnership with
um mgm then because
the rights to the book are in the public
domain but the movie is still under
copyright so anything that was
unique to the movie which would include
the songs and the specific iconography
things like the ruby slippers because in
the book they were silver
that sort of stuff the rights to those
would have to be licensed
from who whoever currently has the
rights to the film which again i think
is mgm
i don't know at this point though i
mentioned the darker nbc oz adaptation
emerald city a few streams ago what i
forgot to mention is that it's directed
by tarsum
singh so it was probably very pretty and
not very good
tarsus thing only had one good movie in
him it was the fall
and it's great but like
seriously do you have trouble staying
still long enough
for the nails to dry too pretty sure her
adhd is the call but for me
um well yes in so far as i generally
don't stay still at all i just try and
keep
you know my my fingers out of harm's way
but i will eventually
do something very casually and forget
um and uh rather frequently screw up a
nail
because of that
uh if you could morph into another body
like jekyll and hyde
what would you do with your second
identity
you're talking to a gender fluid person
who has
two very distinct i mean they're blended
at this point but has historically had
two very distinct online footprints one
for council of geeks and one for vera
wilde
that's already my life
[Laughter]
um what are your thoughts on space jam
i've never seen it all the way through
so i don't really have any
uh
oh some oh headed out cara i hope you
have a good night
i'm not getting uh recommendations for
stuff i've already watched but i am
still getting anti-whatever i'm
interested in rex
yeah there's a lot of stuff my eyes just
kind of
slide off these days there was a meme
that stated that
a modern wonder woman
wonderful a modern wonder years would
start in 2001.
rebecca in this moment
i hate you it'll pass but in this moment
if you were to um die right now oh god
what kind of animal do you want to come
back as
i don't know i
that's like that's the kind of question
that like
not to be mean but it's actually not
good for me
like to just to open a question with
if you died please don't do that that's
like bad for my head space
to start
i know you meant well and we're just
trying for fun but
favorite stop-motion animated movie um
might be paranorman uh personally
have you seen the star trek movie of
2009 oh yeah of course
not in a while um but i have
i mean your body completely changes and
isn't nathaniel
or very third idea if you will i have no
idea
um like my point wasn't so much that
that i live precisely the scenario that
you were
dictating my point was more i've already
gone about physically changing my body
into what i wanted it to be
so i don't know how to start approaching
a question that's basically like
what what other
uh physical body and identity would you
like to have i'm like well i've got one
that i had
i have the one i have now which i like
more i'm like the idea of thinking up a
third
like i i'd be pulling it out of my butt
i'm really happy with what i've got
i i can't quite um extend out into the
thought exercise to do it justice
uh how much would you like the mcu to
use
i'm not gonna say the name uh because
it's a spoiler uh but the
actor who appeared um
at the end of the most recent episode of
wandavision
um i don't know
i definitely want him to be a heavy
feature in the remainder of
the show no question about that
but um i think whether or not i
i believe he even has a place and the
rest of the mcu
is going to depend very heavily on
where things pan out for the remainder
of one division
um but like i like him as an actor and i
like him as this character so
broadly speaking i'm certainly open to
the possibility but like i
i need to know what the context would
possibly be
coming out of one division
uh did you know they tried to get alan
moore to write for doctor who in the 80s
i'm not shocked by that
moore apparently said every doctor after
hartnell
came off as a oh okay i'm not
i'm not actually going to say that word
because i'm pretty sure that's one of
those words that gets you
flagged but um
alan moore is um
is not known for his delicate touch
and uh yeah
any classic who reviews coming soon yes
later this month i actually
um just recently had a poll on the
patreon
um where the patrons could vote on what
the next one would be
we're going to be doing fifth doctor
later this month
so and that'll be in the break room
so pardon me while i
dress this third nail
there we go it's funny some of these
shades really need two coats some of
them you get away with one
if there's a jekyll and hyde broadway
revival you should play the lead
i don't know i like my only exposure to
that show
was the um
[Music]
uh oh god
david hasselhoff a version so like i
have a hard time
thinking of it as like a real thing uh
do you have a favorite style or color
for your nails what style or color do
you want to try i mean like
you can see my nails are uh
are a smorgasbord of uh of nonsense
i would i would really like to get
like legitimate gels
on my nails at some point you know the
ones that like get dried under the lamp
and are really shellacked on and they
they don't chip and you can actually
like grow your nails out decently long
with those because i mean otherwise your
nails are just gonna chip
um i'd like to get that done
uh as a style in terms of color i have
no idea
can you impersonate hercules mulligan
i'm
i'm going to politely decline
doing so um in any sort of extended
manner just because i don't
i'm just um probably overly cautious
about the perception of
um misrepresenting a
a black character or a black actor so
you'll forgive me for that like i've
indulged in it lightly
in a few places like i think i've done
the
[Music]
the bruh thing uh here and i did like a
bit on
tock once but as much as i love the part
i'm like i'm i'm just i'm antsy if
there's something that i he
have even slight second thoughts about
i'm like yeah probably best not to do it
who is the better spider-man toby
maguire andrew garfield or tom holland
it's tom holland he
he just is um i know i have some friends
who really prefer tobey maguire and i
think
whether or not you go for tobey maguire
is directly related to how strong your
nostalgia is
for the original spider-man comics like
from the 60s into the 70s
because toby maguire is a pretty good
representation of
that era of spider-man
whereas i feel i feel like holland is a
very
good update of the general template of
spider-man uh and is a bit more to my
liking
if you were to play sweeney it's just so
many of these questions are like if you
were to play this stage
character i enjoy it it's just funny to
me uh how would you do
the exclamation he does in a little
priest when he realizes what
mrs lovett is suggesting i don't know it
would depend on the
delivery um from the actress playing mrs
lovett
um because it's a reaction to
um something that she
says so i i can't
tell you how i would play a reaction
when i don't know
how the actor doing the original uh
thing that i'm reacting to
is doing because a reaction in a vacuum
that's meaningless it has to be reacting
to something specific
and there are many ways to play mrs
lovitz end of that and depending on that
would impact how i would play that
there's your roundabout answer
snobby actor highfalutin answer
they said that scarlet witch isn't a
thing it's just
wanda they also said uh ultron didn't
kill
p pietro um
who's they in that statement
alex i don't know who they is
if hamilton ever gets made into a movie
you should play the elite
no no no i shouldn't
the the fact that that show
has the diverse cast that it does and
the only
white people are either in the chorus or
king george
is really kind of central to
what it's doing and i think the idea of
casting someone as
white as me in any
thing that aside from king george which
i would happily play if offered
um would be a disservice
i think tom holland is closer to modern
spidey toby is closer to classic spidey
but on the whole i think source material
aside i think the raimi films are the
best ones
i i stand by spider-man 2.
um spider the the first spider-man
it's one of those movies that's really
hard to
talk about um
and um
it it's because its influence kind of
dwarfs the movie itself i feel the same
way about
richard donner superman which is
massively influential an incredibly
important film
a perfectly cast lead role but it's not
a movie i actually enjoy all that much
i think sometimes when something is so
influential and so impactful
it's difficult to separate its impact
from its qualities
and
for me personally i don't really love
the original spider-man
at this point i remember when it came
out
i loved it when it came out
but as time has gone on and other
films have done i think this character
in specific
better and superheroes in general better
i see the importance
of what raymie did and the influence it
had on
what we are now getting but i like what
we're getting now better for the most
part
how would you deliver the line from
sweeney todd i sir i am sir entirely at
your
uh disposal i don't remember who he says
that to
it's been a little while actually
you want an oscar for your performance
in the hamilton movie what's your
reaction
how did i get here in a time warp where
i accepted that role
when i said i wouldn't do it who bent
time to get me here
um how worried are you for the mcu
spider-man 3
i'm i don't have reason to be yet
so no more than any other
uh do you have a favorite villain i've
actually been
trying to sort that out in my head i
don't know if i have an all-time
favorite villain
i need i need to work that out how often
do your top 10
lists change as your taste shift almost
every time i give one
[Laughter]
they they're almost never the same
uh
what's the second best quality to look
out for in a partner
second best
um
i don't know i feel like i'm coming in
late to a conversation
um
i can't answer that because i have um
i have like in in my head sort of the
high
ranking top priority items that are that
are kind of of equal importance and all
need to be present
um but also i say that
you know as an assessment of the
relationships i mean like
i haven't dated i haven't been on a date
a first date in the dating pool
since i was in college so
i i don't think you want to be taking
any dating advice from me
i've seen the new look jared the new
look jared leto joker and do you have
any thoughts and feelings on it
sadness because it reminded me that
we're gonna have to see him as the joker
at least
one more time
am i out of water
i'm out of water
ah
to answer uh your answer from still
feels like 2020 live stream yes
i do have a tick tock but it's under a
different name ah
gotcha
lin manuel is golden globe nominated for
best actor in hamilton
but david diggs has been best actor
nominated for
it by sag yes and um
james corden has also been nominated by
the golden globe so
don't uh don't take them too seriously
during a sword scene they asked if wanda
went by a nickname and they said no so
scarlet witch isn't a thing also a
similar
thing in another sword scene they asked
about ultron and pietro
um so like i remember the scarlet witch
thing just asking if she had a code name
but like
that's literally just a name
and at this point it would be weird for
her to adopt one when she's been in
what four
movies just as wanda
yeah no it would it would have been
weird to just uh
sign her uh a code name now
any particular way you'd like to see
jody would occur to end her run as the
doctor
not bogged down in whatever the heck
chipnell is doing with the timeless
children
i want whatever
note she goes out on to feel
personal i think in hindsight
in a lot of ways that's part of why i
don't especially love
tenants uh regeneration
and i do really love
um at least the build-up to uh
capaldi's regeneration because with
tenant
it felt like it was all about scale and
bombast and messianic importance
whereas capaldi
between both the doctor falls and
twice upon a time felt
smaller it felt personal
and i connected with that much much more
so what i don't want to have happen is
whenever her time ends i don't want it
to be in some
blaze of glory tied to the timeless
child i want it to be smaller i want it
to be more personal i want to be sure
that i feel like i know her
because i still waver on that sometimes
uh but just imagine what if jared leto
is actually good in the fight
in that five second episode what a twist
uh
jared leto i
i just i don't have a lot of use for him
at this point
peter capaldi is supposed to be in the
new suicide squad movie it's not
supposed to be he
is it's confirmed we have uh production
uh stills of him on set in costume so
yeah no we know he is
is there anything i can actively do here
other than throw
endless questions at you well i mean
you can do a super chat and throw
endless amounts of money at me
it's an option i'm just saying
do you have a favorite robin i kind of
favor tim drake
if i'm being honest i like
dick but oh god someone's gonna clip
that
and use it out of context i like dick
grayson but i like him better as
nightwing than as robin i like him
as someone who has the baggage
of having been robin
but who is trying to move on from that
i find him way more interesting when
he's that than when he's just
being robin and
um jason todd was only interesting when
he was dead
and damian can suck on a tailpipe
so there you go
leto is getting award nominations for
the little things
like he's fine and it's just the movie's
not great
um
which of the first three announced
marvel shows were you most excited for a
one division low here winter soldier i
think it was initially most excited for
loki
um
is snyder just ducking everything he was
ever going to do with the
uh chucking everything he was going to
do with the dceu
into the cut look at what you could have
had it does kind of seem like that
because like at this point here's what's
weird about this oh thank you
bookworm thank you very much
um here's the thing that's really really
weird to me
about the snyder cut at this point in
time
it's no longer oh
yes sorry carowind ice i see um
discord i see it thank you i'm gonna
answer this question and jump in
sorry i missed it when you nudged me
before
you can spank me later what um
so uh here's the thing that's really
weird about the snyder cut at this point
the original pitch was supposed to be
you know release the standard cut show
us the movie
we would have gotten but that's not what
we're gonna get
anymore it's now what like four hours
long it was
never ever going to be released
in this state and i know some people
will say well originally it was going to
be two movies and that's like the length
of two movies yeah but by the time he
was shooting
it was already planned to be just one
so what we are going to be getting
is not at all what the original pitch
was going to be
so in a way yeah we're
kind of getting everything that he
might have done shoved into this
i think like i'm not shocked that he has
pumped so much
into it um but
i am kind of surprised that warner
brothers has let him get away with it
they really
i i'm not i really wonder if they're
having buyer's remorse because it's cost
them about
double to produce this thing as what it
was supposed to cost them
which i called by the way
so yeah they're going to end up with a
product that is just as divisive as the
first one
and it's uh yeah i i think they're going
to end up with buyer's remorse on this
for how much they spent
and what they're going to get out of it
any good stuff in the patreon queue
sorry if that's a bad question
um so depend if you mean by patreon you
do you mean the commissioned
reviews yeah there's some there's some
very good stuff
there i've got um i've got a bunch of
bond movies i need to get to
i've got a bunch of star trek episodes
to see i need to check out some episodes
of
um excuse me the tv show heroes
i have got uh several books
which is the thing that is hardest for
me
to keep up with and make steady progress
on
i really got out of the habit of reading
and unfortunately
some of the books including the one i'm
currently working on
um are not available on audible
and i got used to leaning on audiobooks
peek behind the curtain um but
i um i don't
it's it's hard for me like especially
with adhd
to sit down and read a book
audiobooks are good because i can do
something else
while it um while i'm listening to it
even if it's just fiddle on my phone
it's really hard for me to zero in and
focus in um
on reading oh
uh thank you uh oli
circa ten dollars thank you mwah all
right i need i
i told carol when i would pop over to
the discord so i gotta pop over to the
discord
back in a minute all right
make sure you get your water of course i
always get my water are you reading
anything for fun at the moment
for fun no um at this point all my
reading
is stuff that i've been commissioned to
do or is for
um the podcast that i do with liz uh
tough like a girl
um which is our if you aren't familiar
with it
is our um
[Music]
podcast reading um trade paperbacks
and graphic novels with female
protagonists
so uh we actually for
february we're doing a she-ra graphic
novel so that was the last thing that i
finished reading and then um
like i said i'm i'm working i'm working
my way through accession
uh which is good it's actually i'm
enjoying it quite a bit
i'm liking it more than player of games
uh so far
uh e m banks book the but like i said
the issue is i can't
i can't get that one on audiobook in the
us for
some stupid copyright related reason
uh and as a result it is embarrassingly
slow going
it is really hard for me to sit down for
an extended period
and really and really hammer away at it
which is what i need to do
would you like to see a well done live
action tim drake and a batman
blockbuster
maybe but
only if
they put the emphasis on batman as a
detective
because that's part of what makes tim
draken interesting
is that he really gets into the
detective side
of batman um
so i would say only
bring him into the movies um
pardon me i have to do top coats on
these uh
nails so that they last at least a
little longer
um he
they need to move away from the brutal
just beats everybody up until he gets
results batman that they've been doing
for a while now
would you like to see a 60th anniversary
five doctor celebration
um i mean i'd like to see something done
for the 60th
whether i would want to be five doctors
i don't know like i'm not gonna pin
specific expectations or hopes on it
because that's just
usually not what i what i tend to do
uh you can text a speech almost any book
in digital pdf format
i can recommend apps if needed um
i i'm not uh given the way the book's
written i don't think that's good that's
actually gonna work well
either uh if you've ever read the book
you would know what i mean
uh would you like to see a shira
animated movie
no and the only reason i say that is
the story is so complete i don't even
know where you would slot in a movie
like in the continuity and i don't
really
want a continuation it ended really well
uh would you do and among us live
for patreon or something uh that's
actually an idea i floated
um the idea of of doing
um like a like a patron
game night and doing among us so like
that is something that i
i do want to try and do um
in future but uh it is also one of those
things that like
i've got to get some other stuff sorted
um to try and uh
to to try and get on top of some
projects that
really i i really wish were further
along
than they are i'm mainly talking about
editing
the book which is um turned into a much
more
laborious process from my end not my
editor my editor is great
but my contributions to that process my
revisions based off the edit notes is
a bit of a slog of a process
and it's um it's gotten hard oh what is
going on with this one
oh that's all bunched up at the top ah
dang it
might even have to redo that
uh what do you think about peter pan the
character
um i think it that's gonna depend
completely on the interpretation i think
he's a
very malleable character um because you
can you can do peter
pan anything from you know freewheeling
innocent to
uh creepy immortal
kidnapper child thing so like he's
like a lot of classic um
literature characters who have had a
fair number of adaptations over the
years he's fairly malleable
oh no the joker's forcefully had his
tattoos removed by the
um arkham orderlies i think they did him
a favor
what is going on with this
have a good night everyone you too uh
leprechaun i actually i need to
wrap this up well
soon can i
fix this can i fix that
no i'm gonna i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
have to take the
the color on this nail off and start
over
did you ever watch class i never did i
never did get around
with that one
ugh after the end in epilogue they could
introduce a one and done villain
and touch on adoring catra as cute gf's
except watching them get to that point
like
really ultimately was the show i said
no i don't think so
uh if you ever got the chance i check
out the eighth doctor
novels it's fascinating uh to see how
they inspire the new series
um i believe you i just kind of prefer
to stick to the big finish stuff
uh i think the 14th doctor's first
episode
being the 60th with older doctors
returning could be interesting
you could have 14 struggle with who they
are and then finding themselves
i
[Music]
i i would like them to stop having the
regenerations as part of the specials
if i'm being completely honest
do you think easing off on 10's uh intro
and introducing the first appearance of
the time lords
were uh uh our
td implementing methods from trout and
zera for
new who's second doctor um
i don't know you'd have to ask him
like that's you that's me trying to
interpret his intent and i'm just not
gonna really do it class review went
when somebody pays me
i'm sorry i keep hammering on that but
that's really kind of gonna be the
answer until i'm
caught up on a lot of stuff that i'm
very behind on um the answer to
when are you gonna review x unless it's
something that's out fresh
so like when it's a sin
finally hits um
ah crap did did i just go dead
oh no cool uh when it's a sin finally
hits hbo max
i will review that because it's new and
i want to see it
um when the snyder cut comes out i will
review that because it's new and i think
it'll be
funny but um for anything that's been
out for a while the answer is
either when somebody pays me or when i
have free time
and given how far behind i am on the
stuff that i have been paid to review
should give you an idea of how much free
time i actually have
do you agree that they should have a
story a story
story ah a story
started with one doctor and then it's a
regeneration then finished with the next
i hate that they always regenerate
at the end of a story i think that would
be an interesting thing to try
um i think the closest we've ever had to
that
was uh actually the movie uh with paul
mcgann
uh where um
[Music]
sylvester mccoy is in the opening
bit not for too long but a little
forget it's a sin i'm still waiting for
staged
one of these days you should check out
the youtuber dream sounds i actually
have started watching dream sound stuff
um yeah no it's good i haven't done a
deep dive into it but it's good
has anyone paid you to review
disenchantment season three they have
not
uh and i meant to jump on it when it
came out
but i didn't and it has slipped down my
priority list
and actually you know i i watched the
first episode
of season three and realized crap
i don't remember almost
anything about what has gone on with the
story in this show
which i think might speak to it being a
little bit of a mistake
that they opted to go with a continuing
story
because i don't remember a lot of this
stuff
mid-season regen could be awesome but if
they did it with jody i feel like it
would be unfair
she's been shafted enough by jim noll's
writing
aw crap am i buffering i think i'm
buffering
uh oh no there we go all right i
actually need to wrap it up
uh any prediction for this week's wand
division nope
i'm not a prediction person i suck at it
i don't do it generally have you heard
of everywhere at the end of time
nope i have not um
the experimental six hour long album
about
dementia i definitely have not
i don't think i would enjoy that like
dementia's one of my
deep-seated fears uh
i don't think i would like that at all
i'll give you a hint uh on
how i am on tock but don't say my name
out loud
uh on on your bodies are weird video i
said
i have a birthmark on the right side of
my ribs oh i'll have to go back and
check the comments on that one then
uh do you think low key should be
redeemed no i think he should be allowed
to wreak havoc and let's have fun with
it
uh what's your opinion on the rumors
that spider-man might be gay in the next
film i don't have opinion on rumors
um and he won't be the rumor was that he
would be bi
um okay yeah
people are firing more questions at me i
gotta i gotta wrap up i gotta wrap up
thank you all for joining me i hope you
that you have a
uh lovely rest of the week i hope that
um if you have cause to celebrate it
i hope that you have a very nice
valentine's day
and if you don't have cause to celebrate
it i hope you are able to enjoy in the
cheap chocolate the day after
so thank you very much for joining me
and
please remember that you are beautiful
you are valid you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
ah dang it
ah it didn't cut off right when i wanted
it to
mess that up bye